There's some things money can't buy.
We don't like the idea of treating
parts of the body as commodities.
As beautiful a sentiment
as altruism is,
it just isn't enough.
People have two kidneys
situated on the back,
behind the ribcage,
they look more or less like a bean.
And kidneys are organs that filter
waste material from the blood
and process that into urine.
They're extremely important,
because if your kidneys are failing,
you're collecting quite
a bit of waste material
which is detrimental
for all other organ systems.
A typical dialysis patient has
a poorer life expectancy
than many cancers.
After decades of experimenting,
in 1954 was the first
successful human transplant, which
revolutionised the field.
My daughter was involved
in a car accident.
It was clear that her injuries
weren't survivable.
But Fi had let us know that,
if anything had happened,
she would want to give her organs.
So when we arrived at the hospital
and were given that devastating news,
this felt like something that
we could all get behind
and for something positive to come
out of such a sad time.
I mean what an incredible legacy.
Fi saved four people's lives
on that day.
In 2006 I went for a regular check-up
and I felt fine,
but the blood work that I got
showed that my kidneys were
in very, very bad shape.
I had to either go on dialysis,
hooked up to a machine
for three to four hours a day,
about three times a week,
or I would have
to try to find a donor.
Lots of people still don't know
that many people could
actually donate a kidney.
Removing one kidney should
not affect someone's lifespan.
And also should not affect
someone's life quality.
A kidney from a living donor
in general
will have a much better quality
because it comes from
a healthy and tested person.
Kidneys are expected to survive
up to twice as long on average
in the recipient.
I was lucky,
I had two people who were willing
to sacrifice a body part to me.
It leaves you speechless
with gratitude,
but it also leaves you speechless
with sorrow and anger
that there are so many people
who don't have friends or relatives
who can give them a kidney
and who die waiting
for one to become available.
So that's how I became
very interested
in our organ transplant system
and how we should change it.
No-one needs two kidneys,
and there are many desperate
people who need one.
If they were compensated
their lives could be improved
at little cost to their health,
while saving the life
of someone else.
The idea is to offer people
an in-kind benefit,
not cash,
but maybe loan forgiveness,
or a tuition voucher,
or a contribution to their
retirement account
in exchange for a kidney.
If I were a patient
with failing kidneys,
and I faced a short
and miserable life,
and I had the opportunity
to buy a kidney,
and was assured that the donor
was being properly compensated,
you bet I'd take that option.
Currently it's not allowed
to donate a kidney
under any form of payment.
We rely on the goodwill
of people to help others.
It's not the wealthy who would
be wanting to sell their organs,
it's people who are
on the poverty line,
in very desperate situations.
And those people are also
the most vulnerable people
in terms of poor health
in later life.
Incentivising people to donate more
is actually a way to starve
black markets,
it's not to recreate them,
it's to undermine them.
If you reward a person amply
for the sacrifice they've made,
something they go into with their
eyes open and well informed,
that's not exploitation.
No-one really knows what will happen
if you start doing this.
Because even though personally
I'm not necessarily fully against it,
if it would drive people to donate,
but the effect could be that it all
becomes a business transaction.
And that the more obvious donors
may not donate because
they will tell the recipient,
"Oh, you can go and buy
a kidney, right?"
It might actually reduce the number
of people that want to donate,
because they don't want
to be involved in such a scheme.
All of a sudden,
transplantation becomes...
a thing that you can organise
as long as you can pay for it.
People are dreaming to build
kidneys in the laboratory,
bio-printed or 3D-printed
organ structures,
modified pig organs,
so that's a revolution.
This is the only way
to solve the problem.
It's so much needless death.
It feels like an incredible gift,
and I don't know how that gift
can be quantified.
When we're considering
this policy option,
most of us don't weigh
the pros and cons,
but often we're offended
at the very idea.
Selling kidneys is so immoral
I can only liken it to the woman
who goes out on the street
and sells sex.
It's an example of a secular taboo.
In my view, the full potential
of living donation
has not yet been achieved
without using money.
Why are we not maximising
deceased donation?
We don't talk about our wishes.
Research shows that most people
would agree, after death,
to organ donation.
Yet we leave our
loved ones wondering.
Ideally, we could change the law
but I would advocate that anyone
consider donating, no matter what,
because, save dragging someone out
of a burning building
or pulling them out of a frozen lake,
where else could you
save someone's life
so palpably as this?